زياره الرئيس السوني سمحت لبوتين باظهار
انه ليس معزولا دوليا خاصه وان الصين لم
تدن الحرب الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا وهي ملتزمه
بمفاوضات السلام زعيم بيكين كان واضحا في
تاكيدها ان بلاده طول العلاقات مع روسيا
اولويه على اعتبار ان البلدين قوتان
كبريان جارتان استراتيجيان ومن هذا
المنطلق طرحت الصين مبادراتها للحل في
اوكرانيا وهي مبادره تحظى بتقدير زعيم
الكريم الذي قال انه يدرسها باحترام غير
ان الدول الغربيه تعتبر ان دعم بيكين
لموسكو لا يسمح لها بان تكون وسيطا ذا
مصداقيه الرد على اتهام الغربي جاء على
لسان المتحدث باسم كريم
والذي قال ان الولايات المتحده والدول
الغربيه تمنع اوكرانيا من التفكير في اي
محادثات سلام بين موسكو وكياف وذلك في
الوقت الذي يستقبل به الرئيس بوتين نظيره
الصيني في الكلام الذي سيناقش خطه السلام
الصينيه المطروحه بين موسكو وكيف اما من
وجهه نظر بوتين فالعلاقات تدخل رحله جديده
بين موسكو وبكين بغض النظر عن حسابات
اوكرانيا
الدراسي العمليات الحسابيه التجاريه التي
تجري بين روسيا ودول اسيا وامريكا
اللاتينيه وافريقيا سوف تتطور ضمن العملات
الوطنيه وبالدول الاخرى ايضا يمكن ان تتم
عبر اليون وهناك ايضا تعاون في بناء
الطيران المدني وبناء السفن وصناعه
السيارات ونحن مستعدون لدعم الاعمال
الصينيه في تعويض الشركات التي انسحبت من
السوق الروسيه